car hier à tours ptit clap le camp paix
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
deuxième père 15e 15e 15e 15e alors
qu'est ce que vous pensez de 15 acte de
cette 15e faire de cette 15e père voilà
dix 14e alors qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette on est un peuple plein de
ressources on na waie gens qu'elles sont
là un problème est ce que tu peux aussi
mais sur intervention de son choix et on
se l'est puis aller où voilà c'est un
bon camarade way
nous sommes revenus aux questions
pensait de cette 13e perles ces montants
allez c'est parti
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
quinzaine d'heures par exemple les
prochains c'est charly et lulu par
exemple les prochains c'est spirou et
fantasio non plus compliqué j'ai des
bouées une merde à doha les attaques et
des allumettes ça a explosé c'est
beaucoup trop long à temps
[Musique]
vasic et les scores non mais tu vas
faire ça sans protection calcul youtube
n'est revenu annuel youtube manet j'ai
déroulé les mers où j'ai déroulé une
merde allez exploser le paquet là dedans
l'action débute très bien le nord de la
france c'est l'un des musées naturels
les plus célèbres qui inspirait emile
zola emile zola dans l'egypte
émile emile et images qui inspire et
emile zola dans l'un des livres les plus
célèbres du dans l'année où j'ai des
maux les humeurs jeune j'ai lâché 2 mais
n'a pas craqué une allumette a explosé
[Musique]
mais un peu de carottes mend à 40 jours
on lui par sécurité photo nettoyées par
les ex tu connais toi père tu as mais
moi ça m'a amené là et pas fichu cet
hôtel un way pour meetic 1
robert lanza jusqu'à l'autel on va alors
ça 6,9 à la fidélité pas les oreilles
ils sont hyper dur c'est très drôle
c'est pour ma fille allait vraiment tout
petit effet bataille à peu près qu'à
inspiré emile zola dans l'un des
célèbres chutes un média qui a inspiré
emile zola dans l'un des plus grands
livres du monde qui inspire et emile
zola dans l'un des deux plus qui inspire
et zola plus quand même but de flûte
c'est inconscient soit bon je le cherche
surtout attention match bien sinon tu
vas mal digérée bah ouais mais brûlures
d'estomac
[Musique]
le plat du jour c'est pas nouveau ça tu
as toujours secure garde plat du jour
cette voie là
et puis je m'habille comme un bradage
pour le jour aux minettes 1 en tout cas
j'encourage tous les poteaux vendeurs et
vendeuses parce que vous faites un
métier bien relou n'importe quoi le
lapsus je sais pas
c'est avec les risques
[Musique]